you think I'm evil I am justice I
protect the innocent of those who fear
evil I'm the one that will become God of
a new world that everyone desires and
all those who oppose God they are the
ones who are truly evil hello and
welcome to Death Note 101 series breaks
down everyone and everything in the
Death Note world today we're going to be
taking a look at the brilliant high
school student slash mass murderer
self-proclaimed God and series
protagonist all wrapped into one neat
little package right Yagami Light Yagami
is a hard-working and extremely
intelligent high school student who
wished to use his natural gifts to fight
evil in the world by becoming a police
officer just like his father soichiro to
reflect his mental maturity like dresses
in very formal clothing such as school
uniform suits and acts very kindly and
respectfully towards those who are close
to him these features went on to earn
him a lot of admiration from teachers
are the students and of course his
family however another attribute light
would develop was a particularly potent
sense of justice a feeling that would
grow so strong that it would come to
affect lights whole life as well as the
entire world and he just so happened to
find a notebook that fell from the sky
this item was of course the titular
Death Note and it contained the
instructions that anyone whose name was
written in it and whose face the writer
knows shall die now light being a man of
rationality dismiss this as nonsense at
first but curiosity would eventually get
the better of him and when he discovered
that the Death Note does indeed work he
rather quickly decided to use it in
order to clear the world of those who he
considers evil actively pursuing his own
personal brand of justice and after
writing dozens of names into the Death
Note and thus killing dozens of people
light encountered the Shinigami ruk who
explained that Oh books rules to him in
more detail such as the fact that one
can control the actions of the people
whose names are written in it before
ultimately killing them and armed with
this new information and a funky
Shinigami companion let's set out on a
new mission thinking of it as the
ultimate act of sacrifice for the good
of humanity and he continued to kill
criminals going on to develop a
legendary persona amongst the media who
labelled this mysterious murderer as
Kira however these actions would soon be
noticed by the international police as
well as by the legendary detective known
as el in order to commence the hunt for
Kira el concocted a plan to bait the
murderer out using a public broadcast
system that would be played in
individual regions of Japan and due to a
newfound sense of arrogance light would
fall for this ploy and allow el to
discover that Kira was based in the
Kanto region as a result of being bested
on this occasion
viewing Elle as a rival of sorts the
person who he must overcome before he
could truly start crafting his utopia
and from this point forward we as an
audience were blessed with witnessing
one of the greatest cat-and-mouse games
in the history of entertainment there is
no doubt that if it were anyone have
even slightly lesser intelligence they
would have been caught by L in no time
however as a natural genius might
displayed an incredible amount of
ingenuity calmness and supreme foresight
in regards to the actions of his
opponents often resulting in his
overwhelming victory so for example I
was successfully able to deal with 12
count him 12 FBI agents that were sent
to Japan in order to locate and capture
Kira and he did so by manipulating one
agent by the name of Ray penber into
writing down all of the other agents
names onto a page of the Death Note thus
resulting in their demise before light
proceeded to kill break himself although
lights victories were not without
consequences and in this case this led
to some future problems as Penn burrs
fiancee now me me sorta started to look
into the Kira case herself and while
light managed to deal with her as well
it does lead L to setting his sights on
light at this point the mental battle
between light and L became significantly
more intense as L embarked on a gambit
of revealing his identity to light and
inviting him to join the task force
designed to capture Kira and thinking
that it would give him a chance to
figure out a way to kill L might
accepted this proposal the battle didn't
just remain between light and elder as
it was soon revealed that there was
another person using a Death Note to
kill people the second Kira as she
became known was a 19 year old model and
actress named me so Imani
with whom lights are use due to her
possessing the Shinigami eyes meaning
that she had made a deal to exchange
half of her lifespan for the eyes of a
Shinigami which can see people's true
names just by looking at their face
should also be noted the line had the
opportunity to pursue this deal with
Ryoka however he came to the conclusion
that half his lifespan was far too high
a price to pay and so light began
incorporating Misa into his plans during
which two things would become apparent
one was that Misa was in love with light
and two is that light is kind of a dick
I mean on top of being a mass murderer
with a god complex he went on to
blatantly used Misa for his own personal
gain and even planned on simply killing
her if she were to become useless
however because L is L it didn't take
long for him to figure out who the
second Kira was leading to Misa Swift
capture which put light unto even more
suspicion as L had already theorized
that the first and second Kira were in
contact with each other now in order to
combat this light formed a very
convoluted but phenomenal plan to hurt
mrs. Shinigami REM erased their memories
of anything to do with the Death Note
and furthermore to provide a man by the
name
Yosuke huh cookie with a Death Note in
order for him to continue the Kira
killings while site and Mesa were under
intense observation thus simultaneously
creating the third Kira as well as
clearing light and Misa of all
suspicions however with the
self-inflicted amnesia we would be
treated to an entirely different side of
light as he earnestly put his efforts
into hunting down Kira during which he
and Elle actually became incredibly
close colleagues without even providing
a great source of moral support and
motivation this light was just so
profoundly different to the one we as
the audience near showing that where he
never to have encountered the Death Note
in the first place he probably would
have been a genuinely compassionate and
traditionally morally upstanding human
being without its corrupting influence
but this wholesome family fun light
would not last long as combining his
intellect with Elle resulted in who
guchi becoming quickly captured and
following the slight regained his
memories upon touching the apprehended
Death Note so with everything having
gone all according to keikaku but then
implemented the final stage of his grand
plan which saw him manipulating the
Shinigami realm into writing the names
of both Elle and his longtime associate
watery thus killing them as well as REM
herself in the process culminating in
lights complete and out of victory with
his rival successfully dealt with might
then took over as leader of the task
force all the while continuing his
original role as Kira for the next five
years managing to gradually reshape the
world through his purge of human society
now while this may be lights happy
ending that certainly was not where
things came to a conclusion has
eventually two successes of Elle emerged
to hunt down Kira being near and Mello
with the former heading up a new
organization known as spk or the special
provision for Kira while the latter
ended up leading an underground mafia
group quite notably it should be said
that these two groups were not working
together and in fact even violently and
fatally opposed each other although it
was the Mafia group led by Mello that
was certainly in the more volatile and
eventually resulted in light's younger
sister being kidnapped a situation in
which we once again treated to a rare
display of humanity from our protagonist
who was quite distraught and put his all
into ridding the world of Mello as
quickly as possible however on this
occasion lights overall plan ended in
failure as well as the death of lights
father Sora after which light sought out
the assistance of two individuals being
Mikami Toto and Kiyomi Takada in order
to battle both near and Mello I gave
becoming a Death Note thus making him
the fourth Kira or the ex cure as he
became known although this was but a
clever ruse as I'd instructed him to
make a duplicate of that Death Note and
forward it's real pages to Takata who
conducted the actual killings however it
would be the acquisition of these two
parties that would ultimately cause
light's downfall as talkative
would be kidnapped by Miller and while
she did manage to kill him this event
caused Nia's spk team to discover and
put me coming under surveillance during
which he revealed the location of the
real death note and it would be this
crucial information that spelt the
difference between global domination and
complete defeat for light shortly after
he and NIR arranged a meeting where
light was planning to kill near the SPK
agents and even the remaining Kira Task
Force members by having me come me write
their names down in what they thought to
be the real death note however it had
since been swapped out for a replica and
having me come me write down everyone's
name in the warehouse except for light
himself became the indisputable proof
that he was in fact Kira forced into a
desperate situation like proudly
admitted being Kira and then attempted
to write Nia's name on a piece of death
note that he had concealed within his
watch at which point he was shot by Tata
Matsuda a member of his own task force
and for me lights ultimate fate differs
depending on whether you were a patron
of the anime or the manga starting with
the manga though and ever maddening
light screamed out to his compatriots
for help pleading for me commie
Takata whom he had killed by them by the
way Misa and finally the Shinigami
reeled in a response to this react then
fulfilled the promise he made light at
the beginning of their partnership and
wrote lights name in his Death Note and
the last thoughts that run through the
head of our protagonist mind in his
final few panic seconds on this world is
simply that he does not want to die now
the anime version of this varies a fair
bit with like managing to escape the
warehouse even whilst riddled with
bullets and near electing not to pursue
him for reasons however seeing the
inevitable fate of his partner similarly
rights lights named down in the Death
Note and as light passes away an
illusion of his former rival L appears
before him mirroring the scene in which
light succeeded in killing him and
bringing light story to a close some
more fun facts about light when
designing lights character Takeshi Obata
was given instructions to draw him as a
genius high-school student to do this he
had used fashion magazines as a guide in
order to figure out what kind of clothes
smart people would wear which is fair
enough I mean I have no idea what a
smart person would wear I'm clearly not
won in the anime when we see light or
any other character for that matter
thinking of something their hair turns a
certain colour this is because albertov
wanted the colors to fit the personality
of the character in question in lights
color just so happens to be bread which
is commonly associated with traits such
as passion determination how are anger
in danger and finally a truly useless
fact during the course of his life
lighters held a total of three different
death notes which is one less than the
total number of death No
introduced in the series and that pretty
much does it for light alchemy if you
enjoyed this video and the content this
channel produced in general and please
do consider donating to the new world
with few patreon because the support of
all of you amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and the patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video well
like share or subscribe because it also
helps support this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time then please do head over to
my discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan ray takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do a comment
with who what or where you'd like to see
featured in the next deathnote 101
I mean really when you think about it
light is probably one of the most
versatile characters in the entire anime
world I mean just look at his range
you've got light yagami Tokyo me
dim Yagami neon Yagami strobe light
yagami moving Light Yagami and even
tungsten Yagami I mean what a guy